help her desk what content do you find
best works for your email marketing
should you emails be targeting your new
prospects or your loyal customers
perhaps separate lists for both groups I
think the answer is in the question
there because you know the answer is
definitely segments content to uh if
you're able to identify you know
non-customers or soon-to-be customers
and your customers that absolutely
provide content that's relevant to each
you know one way to think about it is
that if you have established that list
of I've got a you know I've got a list
of names that are you know people that
aren't customers yet well the content
you want to be focusing for them is most
likely education about your industry or
your service line forget about selling
them let's let's focus on getting them
smart about what it is that that you do
what your industry provides and then
when you come to your customers you know
focus on providing them education around
how to use your product or service or
get the most out of your product or
service because again they've invested
their a customer so you want to go to
nurture mode with that list as well so
yes on segmenting but again think of
education on industry for potentials and
education around your product or service
for customers I love it and I think this
is where autoresponders feel really
powerful yeah for those of for those of
you who don't know what our responders
are it's basically once somebody signs
up for your list at a set schedule and
frequency they get certain emails that
you have pre crafted and so you write
the email once and then you know seven
days later from joining the list they
get that email and then another seven
days later whatever interval you want
they get more emails and so I think the
auto responders are an amazing way to
educate the new people to your list as
well as build Authority and build trust
and be seen as a friend so as example if
you join my email list I have 75,000
people on my list or so uh you know
you'll get at you'll get a welcome email
for me and then it's six days later
you'll get a list of my favorite YouTube
videos and then a week later you'll get
a list of my top 10 books for
entrepreneurs and a weekly to get
another email with the my favorite
quotes for entrepreneurs
just all sorts of kind of value add
stuff that helps me tell the story and
build a relationship and I think that
really helps educate the new people to
your list and then your broadcast so
they're kind of one-off emails that you
can send like when I was promoting this
event I send it to my email list
yesterday morning as a broadcast right I
don't want it to be an autoresponder
because it's happening in a specific
time so this is a broadcast and I'm
sending out and that goes to everybody
goes to my prospects that goes to my
clients eric is there an easy way to
once somebody has purchased from you to
move them to a separate list if I'm
using Aweber yes and there's a way to
tag the customers based on what you know
about them to then set up for a separate
you know series you know focused
primarily on that educational
information so you know we're able to
you're not just doing once you know
somebody is in but also based on where
they're signing up from you know there's
ways to segment based off of that so
that's very powerful because you may be
at an event where it's nothing but
prospects and just by capturing names of
that event you're able to start that
series from from immediately when they
provide you that information or sign up
to the list provide them information
that's focused on prospects because you
knew that they came from an area where
there was nothing but opportunity so
definitely is possible that's
interesting so so if I go to a
conference and you know I'm collecting a
bunch of names and people are you know I
want to send into a page to get more
information and on there is an email
list I can then funnel them to a
separate list where they're getting
information with autoresponders that
talk about that conference right news
maple okay here are 10 things i learned
from the conference that might be
beneficial to you correct and what you
is a business there what you believe was
the best you know outcomes from that
conference of learnings from that
conference you know so all that again it
really forces you to think about when it
comes to building your list and growing
your list you know sometimes those live
events could be very very popular but
also take the same thought process apply
to your blog or your facebook page or
other areas where you're going to be
growing your list because the context of
where all the
the names are coming in you know it's
important it's important because you
know if it's coming from an area where
there may be both prospects and
customers well then you can give the
choice of having somebody self-select
are you a customer yes or no and that
too allows you to trigger or segment off
into you know prospect versus customer
follow-up series cool so so if I'm
building a list of my facebook page I
could then have as my first email some
of my top 10 Facebook posts of all time
yeah welcome them from facebook yeah
it's I mean I think that does a lot to
really build the relationship and make
it seem like you care and it's because
you actually do care hopefully absolute
your clients